From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life .
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。
Mr. Goodman and I get these regularly. Sometimes people think we make them up.
古德曼先生和我经常收到这些。有时人们以为是我们编出来的。
Vincent Homenick and his boss, Norman Goodman, have to enlist 1,800 jurors a day for the state courts of New York City. And they have heard every possible excuse, real and fake, for avoiding jury duty. And they've saved some of them in this very thick folder.
文森特·霍梅尼克和他的老板诺曼·古德曼每天必须为纽约市的州法院征召1800名陪审员。他们听过各种可能的借口，无论是真是假，都是为了逃避陪审义务。他们把其中一些保存在了这个非常厚的文件夹里。
Believe it or not, we still get the old, my cat threw up on the summons and I could not send it in.
信不信由你，我们还是会收到这种老掉牙的借口：“我的猫在传票上吐了，我没法寄回去。”
Here's a summons with cat throw-up on the back. It's red and sort of a mustard color.
这是一张背面有猫呕吐物的传票。是红色的，还有点芥末色。
We get used tubes of Anusol, stating that the woman has hemorrhoids and can't sit. We get pictures. Instead of a doctor's note, they send in pictures of their condition as if we know it's the actual person.
我们收到过用过的痔疮膏管，声称那位女士有痔疮，坐不住。我们还收到过照片。他们不发医生证明，而是发来他们患处的照片，好像我们知道那真的是本人一样。
Oh, this is just a random photo of a man in a wheelchair.
哦，这只是一张随机的坐轮椅男人的照片。
That's right. And he says, as you can see, I'm not able to serve on jury duty.
没错。他说，如你所见，我无法履行陪审义务。
Actually, using a wheelchair, or blindness-- or deafness, for that matter-- will not get you out of jury duty in New York.
实际上，在纽约，坐轮椅、失明，或者就此而言，失聪，都不能让你免除陪审义务。
I got a letter the other day and it was not signed by the doctor.
前几天我收到一封信，上面没有医生的签名。
This is Vincent's boss, Norman, who's been in this job since 1969.
这是文森特的老板，诺曼，他从1969年起就在这份岗位上了。
It was signed by a nurse in the doctor's office. And the nurse said that this prospective juror has a chronic condition. Well, so have we all.
那是医生办公室里的一位护士签的名。护士说这位潜在的陪审员有慢性病。嗯，我们大家都有慢性病。
Wait. It didn't say what the condition was?
等等。信里没说是什么病吗？
Didn't say what the condition was. Just said she's got a chronic condition that prohibits her from serving on jury service.
没说是什么病。只说她有慢性病，导致她无法履行陪审职责。
An unspecified medical condition is one they've seen a lot in their jobs as county clerk and chief clerk. They also encounter a certain amount of rudeness. "Dear County Jerk," one letter opens. "Are you brain-dead?" Many New York citizens send back things we cannot broadcast on their official jury forms.
未指明的医疗状况是他们作为县书记官和首席书记官在工作中经常见到的借口。他们还会遇到一定程度的无礼。“亲爱的县里的混蛋，”一封信这样开头，“你脑死亡了吗？”许多纽约市民在正式的陪审团表格上写了一些我们无法广播的东西。
Now here's one where someone has just scrawled in black pen to F off.
看这一张，有人直接用黑色钢笔写了“滚蛋”。
We, unfortunately, get a lot of these. They seem to think that they can write anything on an official court document, which is not the case. One particular gentleman, during a noncompliance proceeding, blamed his seven-year-old sister for sending in pornography that was attached to our juror qualification questionnaire. The judge did not believe him. The judge did fine him, and he ended up serving.
不幸的是，我们经常收到这种信。他们似乎认为可以在正式的法庭文件上写任何东西，事实并非如此。有一位先生，在违规诉讼期间，把夹在我们陪审员资格调查问卷里的色情读物归咎于他七岁的妹妹。法官不相信他。法官对他处以罚款，最后他还是参加了陪审。
Serving his jury duty, that is. One man wrote in saying that he was simply too racist to be on a jury. But the single most common excuse? People can't afford the time. They're single moms with no childcare. They're people who will not be able to pay the bills if they take off work. They think they are simply too important for jury duty. None of this cut it with Norman and Vincent, by the way. Court clerks talk to these people, try to accommodate their schedule somehow. And part of the formula is the court clerks appeal to their idealism, their sense of duty.
也就是履行了他的陪审义务。有一个人写信说他因为种族歧视太严重，不能参加陪审。但最常见的借口是什么呢？人们负担不起时间。她们是单身母亲，没有育儿服务。如果不上班，他们就付不起账单。他们认为自己太重要了，没时间当陪审员。顺便说一下，诺曼和文森特可不买账。法庭书记官会与这些人交谈，尽量安排他们的日程。其中的秘诀之一，就是法庭书记官会诉诸他们的理想主义和责任感。
You make it a personal thing. I tell them, if you had a case or a family member, you'd want the best jury possible. You'd want a fair cross-section. And that's the only way to get fair jurors is to get a fair cross-section and let everybody be part of it. So it's important that everybody serves.
你要把它变成一件私人的事。我告诉他们，如果你有官司或者你的家人有官司，你会希望有一个尽可能好的陪审团。你会希望有一个公正的代表群体。而获得公正陪审员的唯一途径，就是获得一个公正的代表群体，让每个人都参与其中。所以每个人都参与服务是很重要的。
When you give people that speech, does that work on most people?
当你对人们进行那种说教时，这对大多数人有效吗？
I think it does.
我觉得有效。
And in general-- in general-- people are responsible. People want to serve. They're generous with their time.
总的来说——总的来说——人们是负责任的。人们想要服务。他们慷慨地贡献自己的时间。
And-- not to put too fine a point on it-- they are threatened with fines and jail time if they don't show up. But most do show up. Only 9% of the people who are summoned here for jury duty fail to show. Another 15%, Norman and Vincent say, try to contest or postpone their eligibility.
而且——直白地说——如果他们不出席，他们会受到罚款和监禁的威胁。但大多数人都来了。在被传唤来做陪审员的人中，只有9%的人没有出席。诺曼和文森特说，另有15%的人试图抗辩或推迟他们的资格。
And there is one curious thing that the court's own exit questionnaires show, and that is that people who actually get to sit on a case and hear evidence and get to a verdict say they liked the experience way more than the people who just show up and don't get a case and then actually get to go home earlier. Something kicks in for the people who actually get on to juries. Suddenly, it seems important to do the right thing.
法庭自己的离职问卷显示了一件有趣的事情，那就是那些真正能够参与案件审理、听取证据并达成裁决的人，说他们比那些只是出庭但没摊上案子、然后实际上可以早点回家的人，从这段经历中得到了更多的满足感。对于真正进入陪审团的人来说，某种东西被激活了。突然之间，做正确的事情似乎变得很重要。
Which brings us to today's program. Today we're going to devote our entire show to the story of somebody who gets called for a job that he does not want-- that nobody would want, really. The kind of family obligation all of us face at some point or another, in some form. Though, this guy faces a more extreme version of it than most of us do. And he goes. Because, corny as it sounds, sometimes duty calls. And sometimes it calls you to Florida. Stay with us.
这就引出了今天的节目。今天我们将把整个节目专门用于讲述一个被叫去执行他不想做的任务的人的故事——真的，没人会想做这个任务。这是我们所有人在某个时候、以某种形式都要面对的那种家庭义务。尽管，这家伙面临的情况比我们大多数人都要极端。但他还是去了。因为，听起来虽然老套，但有时职责召唤。有时它会把你召唤到佛罗里达。请继续收听。
When Josh Bearman grew up in suburban Pasadena, his dad worked for NASA-- was a physicist. He had a stepmom, and he had a brother named Ethan.
当乔什·贝尔曼在帕萨迪纳郊区长大时，他的父亲在NASA工作，是一名物理学家。他有一个继母，还有一个叫伊森的弟弟。
That's not his whole family. When we first ran this next story in 2007, his mom was living in Florida along with his half-brother, David. Josh had gone for a while, not spending much time with them, but one day, he had no choice.
那还不是他的全部家人。当我们2007年第一次播出这个故事时，他的母亲正和他的同母异父兄弟大卫住在佛罗里达。乔什有一段时间没怎么跟他们来往，但有一天，他别无选择。
Here's how different the two halves of my family are. My brother Ethan, who grew up with me in California, left high school early for a conservatory, where he studied French horn. He has a house, a wife, a son, and fills in with the LA Philharmonic. But my brother David in Florida, well, here he is.
这就是我家庭两部分之间有多么不同。我弟弟伊森和我一起在加州长大，高中没读完就去了音乐学院，主修圆号。他有房子、妻子、儿子，还在洛杉矶爱乐乐团担任候补。但我在佛罗里达的弟弟大卫，嗯，他现在这副样子。
Yeah, I just got this police report for my DUI, and I'm gonna read it here. But I can already see a couple of things that are absolute bull-[BLEEP]. This wasn't even the original officer, and he's gonna talk about what he saw.
是的，我刚收到这份关于我酒驾的警察报告，我要在这里读一下。但我已经能看出有几点绝对是胡扯。这甚至不是最初的那位警官，他要说他看到了什么。
David's been arrested a bunch of times-- not for anything violent, just a DUI, a shoplifting charge or two. Then there's my father, the nuclear physicist. He sometimes launches at Caltech's Athenaem, surrounded by Nobel laureates. Here's my mom describing someone she might have lunch with.
大卫被捕过很多次——不是因为暴力行为，只是酒驾、一两项扒窃指控。还有我的父亲，那位核物理学家。他有时在加州理工学院的雅典娜神庙用餐，周围都是诺贝尔奖得主。这是我妈妈在描述她可能一起吃午饭的人。
OK, Terron-- I used to call him the creeper. He's a street hustler, and that's all he'll ever be. He's waiting for a liver transplant.
好的，泰隆——我以前叫他“毛骨悚然的家伙”。他是个街头混混，这辈子也就这样了。他在等肝移植。
The last time I lived with my mother, I was nine. After my parents' divorce, my half-brother David-- he was just an infant at the time-- stayed with my mother, and my father got custody over me and Ethan. That's when my mom started drinking seriously. As she got worse, we only caught glimpses of her. Occasional drunken phone calls late at night, a few sightings on family holidays.
我上次和母亲住在一起时，我九岁。父母离婚后，我的同母异父弟弟大卫——当时他还是个婴儿——和母亲住在一起，而父亲获得了我和伊森的监护权。那时我妈妈开始严重酗酒。随着她情况恶化，我们只能瞥见她的一点消息。偶尔深夜醉酒的电话，在家庭假期里见上几次。
For several years in there, I didn't even know where she was. Once, in an effort to connect with her, I arranged for me, my brother Ethan, and my girlfriend Ronnie to all fly across the country to meet my mother and David for a visit at my grandparents' house. My mother didn't show.
有几年，我甚至不知道她在哪里。有一次，为了和她建立联系，我安排我和弟弟伊森、还有女朋友罗尼飞往全国各地，去祖父母家探望母亲和大卫。但我母亲没出现。
A few years ago, my grandparents staged a rescue. They brought my mom and David to Florida, where they all lived among the palm trees and strip malls. It was a strange world down there.
几年前，我的祖父母组织了一次营救。他们把妈妈和大卫带到了佛罗里达，他们全都住在棕榈树和购物中心之间。那里是一个奇怪的世界。
David got into rapping, freestyling at MC battles so he could leave his mark on the greater Palm Beach area hip-hop scene. He made friends with a producer, Jermaine, who was not exactly a producer, but a kid who met David at the Olive Garden and then moved in with him and my mom.
大卫迷上了说唱，在MC对决中即兴表演，这样他就能在棕榈滩地区更大的嘻哈圈留下自己的印记。他和一位制作人杰梅因交了朋友，那人其实不是什么制作人，只是在橄榄园餐厅遇到大卫后，就搬来和他及我母亲住在一起。
At first, I was skeptical of this arrangement, until I realized that Jermaine was the most responsible one of the bunch, with David mostly jobless, and my mom still devising elaborate cover stories for morning trips to the liquor store. These were transparent to me, but often fooled my grandparents, who devoted their final years to trying to manage all this-- posting bail, taking care of rent, paying for treatment plans, and David's $3,000 cell phone bills.
起初，我对这种安排持怀疑态度，直到我意识到杰梅因是他们中间最负责任的一个，大卫大多时候没有工作，而我妈妈仍在为每天早上跑去酒行买酒编造复杂的掩盖故事。这些谎言对我来说一目了然，但往往能骗过我的祖父母，他们晚年的最后时光都花在试图处理这一切上——保释、付房租、支付治疗计划，还有大卫的三千美元手机账单。
I'd visit a few times a year and always felt stunned at the way they lived. I'd have to remind myself sometimes that these people were my immediate family. I didn't understand them, and they played little role in my daily life. Then one day last year, they took over my life.
我一年会去探望几次，总是对他们的生活方式感到震惊。我有时得提醒自己，这些人是我的至亲。我不了解他们，他们在我的日常生活中几乎没起什么作用。然后去年有一天，他们接管了我的生活。
It started with a phone call from David. By this time, my grandparents had both died, and my mom and David lived in my grandfather's condo at Century Village, a retirement community in West Palm Beach. Now David was calling because he was about to start a 30-day jail sentence. Our mother, he said, had been so drunk she hadn't moved from the couch in weeks. He was sure she would die if he left her there.
这始于大卫的一个电话。那时，我的祖父母都已经去世了，母亲和大卫住在西棕榈滩一个叫“世纪村”的退休社区里，那是我祖父的公寓。大卫打电话是因为他马上要开始30天的监禁。他说，我们的母亲醉得太厉害，几周来连沙发都没挪过窝。他肯定如果他离开，她会死在那儿。
I got a neighbor to go over. She took one look at my mother and called an ambulance. When the paramedics brought her to intensive care, the attending physician called me to ask what the hell happened to her. I said I didn't know. The next morning, I got on a plane for Florida.
我找了个邻居过去看。她看了一眼我母亲，就叫了救护车。当护理人员把她送到重症监护室时，主治医生给我打电话，问她到底发生了什么事。我说我不知道。第二天早上，我坐上了去佛罗里达的飞机。
When I arrived, my mom was in the hospital, unconscious, and attached to a tangle of intravenous drips. The DTs would set in over the next few days. It was shocking, but equally shocking was what I saw when I went to her condo. The place was so bad, it looked like a crime scene. The couch had a blackened depression where she'd been sitting for God knows how long. There were overflowing ashtrays, real and improvised, and trash everywhere. It smelled like urine and nicotine. There were burns in the couch, and a 4-foot patch of blackened carpet that looked like someone had spent several days rubbing bong water and soot into the floor on purpose.
我到达时，妈妈躺在医院里，不省人事，身上连着一堆静脉输液管。接下来的几天里，戒断症状开始出现。这令人震惊，但同样令人震惊的是我走进她公寓时看到的景象。那个地方烂得像个犯罪现场。沙发上有一个发黑的凹陷，她在那里坐了天知道多久。到处是溢出的烟灰缸，有现成的也有临时凑合的，还有到处都是垃圾。闻起来像尿液和尼古丁。沙发上有烧痕，还有一块4英尺长、发黑的地毯，看起来就像有人故意花了几天时间把大麻烟斗水和煤灰擦进地板里一样。
It took a month for me to even begin sorting it all out. I arranged for David to complete his jail sentence in the condo under house arrest. When my mother stabilized, I got her transferred to a nursing facility-- the only one that would accept her with no insurance. But that was just the beginning. With my grandparents gone, it was clear that she and David literally had no idea how to survive by themselves.
我花了一个月时间才开始整理这一切。我安排大卫在公寓里完成了家庭监禁形式的服刑。当我母亲情况稳定后，我把她转到了一家护理机构——唯一一家愿意接收没有保险的她的机构。但这只是开始。祖父母去世后，很明显，她和大卫根本不知道如何独立生存。
Now she faced destitution from all the medical bills, and David was on the verge of serious jail time was one more screw up. It began to dawn on me that I couldn't go back home to California. Someone had to help get them back on their feet, and there was nobody left but me. And that's how I wound up spending four months in Florida as a reluctant social worker for my own family.
现在她面临医疗账单带来的赤贫，而大卫只要再搞砸一次就面临重刑。我开始意识到，我没法回到加州的家。必须有人帮忙让他们重新站起来，而除了我之外再无他人。就这样，我不得不在佛罗里达待了四个月，成了自己家人的非自愿社会工作者。
Hi. I've got kind of a strange situation. My mom lives at 240 Bedford J, and she's in the hospital--
你好。我的情况有点奇怪。我妈妈住在贝德福德J区240号，她现在在医院里——
It's a typical Wednesday. My mom's still in the nursing home, but there are various documents I need to pick up from her condo. The problem is Century Village is a rather heavily fortified retirement community. It's set up like some kind of geriatric army base, with many thousands of octogenarians housed in blocks and protected from solicitors and terrorists alike by a big walled perimeter.
这是个典型的周三。我妈妈还在疗养院，但我需要从她的公寓里拿走各种文件。问题是，世纪村是一个防御相当森严的退休社区。它看起来像某种老年人军事基地，有数以千计的八十多岁老人住在这里，通过一圈围墙保护起来，既防推销员，也防恐怖分子。
You can't get past the tightly-monitored gates without having someone add your name to a list or flashing a residence pass. David recently lost his own pass and began resorting to commando tactics-- sneaking in through gaps in the golf course fence, or scaling the wall behind the gas station. I can't get on the stupid list myself, since you can only add visitors' names by calling from within your house. So my mom can't call me in from the nursing home where she's living now. Instead, I have to rely on her neighbors, who are easily confused and don't like to rock the boat.
如果没有人把你的名字加到名单上，或者出示居住证，你就进不去这些严密监控的大门。大卫最近弄丢了自己的通行证，开始采取突击战术——从高尔夫球场的篱笆空隙溜进去，或者翻越加油站后面的墙。我自己没法上那个该死的名单，因为你只能从房内拨打电话添加访客姓名。所以我妈没法从她现在住的疗养院把我叫进去。相反，我只能指望她的邻居们，他们很容易糊涂，也不喜欢惹事。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, it's Josh calling again.
嗨，我是乔什，又打扰了。
Yes?
什么事？
So I called my mom and she couldn't really figure out any other way for me to get in.
我给我妈打过电话，但她实在想不出别的方法让我进去。
Uh-huh.
呃哼。
So I don't know. I wanted to try to return to the idea of maybe you calling me in somehow.
所以我不知道。我想试着回到也许你能帮我打电话叫进去的办法。
Well--
嗯——
The neighbor does not call me in, which is nothing new. But after half an hour, I managed to convince one of the commanding officers of the gatehouse regime to let me through. Inside the wall, Century Village is like its own city. There are acres of condos amongst man-made lakes, and the whole thing is serviced by a pharmacy and general store. There are several club houses and a shuttle system that takes residents to nearby shopping centers.
邻居没有帮我叫进去，这不新鲜。但在半小时后，我终于说服了一位守门 regimes 的指挥官放我通行。在围墙内，世纪村就像它自己的城市。在人造湖泊之间有成亩的公寓，整个地方由一家药房和一家杂货店服务。有几个会所和一个将居民送到附近购物中心的班车系统。
In Century Village-- where the entire place knows when you've put your car in the wrong parking spot-- imagine the impression made by my mother, drunk on the shuttle at noon, or David in a wife-beater, arguing with his pill-popping girlfriend on the grass at midnight. Needless to say, they made for very conspicuous neighbors at 240 Bedford J.
在世纪村——整个地方都知道你什么时候把车停错了停车位——想象一下，中午在班车上喝醉的母亲，或者午夜时分在草地上穿着背心与磕药女友争吵的大卫，会给人留下什么印象。不用说，他们在贝德福德J区240号是非常显眼的邻居。
So I'm just getting to my mom's condo in Century Village. The window's broken. That's from a hurricane. And this place is a real mess. What's in the f-- oh, boy. There's even roaches in the fridge. And there's roaches in the microwave. I should just turn the microwave on. That'll fix that problem. [MICROWAVE BEEPS] [MICROWAVE RUNNING] All right. I'm getting out of here.
我现在刚到我妈在世纪村的公寓。窗户破了。那是飓风造成的。这个地方真是一团糟。什么鬼——哦，天哪。冰箱里甚至还有蟑螂。微波炉里也有蟑螂。我应该直接打开微波炉。那就能解决问题了。[微波炉鸣响][微波炉运行中]好了。我要离开这儿。
It's been about a month since I was here the last time-- since my mom was rushed to the hospital-- and coming back is surprisingly emotional. I looked for this old photo that was in the bedroom on my last visit.
距离我上次来这里——也就是我妈被紧急送往医院的时候——已经过去大约一个月了，回来感觉出奇地情绪化。我找了上次访问时放在卧室里的那张旧照片。
My mom's got a-- there's a picture of her when she was really young. And I saw that and I started crying.
我妈有张——有张她年轻时候的照片。我看到那个就开始哭了。
[CRYING]
[哭泣声]
This is the picture of my mom that sort of made me upset. And it's actually a picture I've seen around for a long time. This is my mom probably when she's 30 years old. My mom was like this happy, healthy, attractive woman. And it reminded me what it meant that my mom has wound up this way. She's unrecognizable when you compare her to this picture.
这就是那张让我难过的妈妈的照片。其实我见过这张照片很久了。这大概是我妈30岁的时候。我妈曾经是这样一个快乐、健康、有吸引力的女人。它提醒我，妈妈落到今天这个地步意味着什么。当你把她和这张照片相比时，你根本认不出她来。
[COUGHING] Excuse me.
[咳嗽声] 对不起。
You've got grandma's cough.
你得了祖母的咳嗽病。
I know. Yeah.
我知道。是啊。
My mom and I are in the car. She's improved considerably since I checked her into the nursing home. At that time, she was still in a wheelchair and couldn't eat solid food. Now she's walking, back up to two packs a day, and complaining about her roommate.
我和我妈在车里。自从我把她送进疗养院后，她情况好转了很多。那时候，她还得坐轮椅，吃不下固体食物。现在她能走了，恢复到每天两包烟，还在抱怨她的室友。
Well, and then for one thing, I was in the same room with Mrs. Ayala, the Jesus freak.
嗯，首先，我和那个耶稣狂热分子阿亚拉夫人住在同一个房间。
Yeah.
是啊。
At 5:00 AM she'd be up yelling, praise Jesus! Glory, hallelujah! And then she turned on the religious station. It'd be on all day. If I attempted to change the channel, she'd start reading Bible verses to me. Then one day, I got annoyed at her. I said, enough is enough. It's been on since 5:30 till 10 o'clock at night. I want to watch a regular show. She called me the devil. That was it. I called Corinne. I said, I'm out of this room.
早上五点她就会起床大喊，“赞美耶稣！荣耀，哈利路亚！”然后她就打开宗教电台。那频道会开一整天。如果我试图换台，她就开始给我读圣经经文。有一天，我被她惹毛了。我说，够了就是够了。从早上五点半一直放到晚上十点。我想看正常的节目。她叫我魔鬼。就这样。我给科琳打电话。我说，我要搬出这个房间。
She called you the devil?
她叫你魔鬼？
Yeah. She says, you're the devil.
对。她说，你是魔鬼。
But she was all friendly when I was there.
但我当时在那儿时她挺友好的。
Oh, yeah. Well, that's her.
噢，是啊。好吧，那就是她。
She's got a whole lot of stuffed animals, that's for sure.
她有很多毛绒玩具，那是肯定的。
From a purely medical perspective, my mother has made a dramatic recovery. Along the way, she's created a whole life for herself at the nursing home.
从纯医学角度来看，我母亲已经有了显著的康复。在此过程中，她在疗养院为自己创造了完整的生活。
And this is the first floor.
这是第一层。
She takes me on a tour, waving at the staff she likes and pointing out all the friends she's made.
她带我参观，向她喜欢的员工挥手，并指出她交到的所有朋友。
I hang out with Jean and Judy, the smokers. Judy's the one that has the cute little shoes. And Jean's the one-- she lives on the second floor. She has a room all to herself. She's older-- yeah, eyepatch.
我和抽烟的简和朱迪混在一起。朱迪就是那个穿着可爱小鞋子的人。简是那个——她住在二楼。她有自己的房间。她比较老——是的，戴着眼罩。
Oh, she's the one with the little designer eyepatch?
噢，她是那个戴着设计师眼罩的人吗？
Yeah. Well, it's not a designer eyepatch.
是啊。不过，这不是设计师眼罩。
Well, it's not black.
嗯，反正不是黑色的。
No. Here's the lady who takes her clothes off all the time.
不。那个是老喜欢脱衣服的女士。
Oh, there she is. Oh, she's in the process right now?
噢，她在那里。噢，她现在正在脱吗？
As far as I'm concerned, she's too comfortable here. This nursing home is fairly grim. Kind of a hellhole, actually.
就我而言，她在这里待得太舒服了。这家疗养院相当阴森。实际上简直是个地狱。
Did you ever see that movie Jacob's Ladder ? You know that scene where Tim Robbins hallucinates being admitted into a hospital run by monsters? It's kind of like that. The place is totally isolated, surrounded by swamp. There are catatonics parked in the halls, drooling. One woman roams around constantly weeping. Michael, a stroke victim, seems to be standing in every corner, staring at you with these sad, hollow eyes. And that's the good floor.
你有没有看过那部电影《雅各布的阶梯》？你知道那个蒂姆·罗宾斯产生幻觉，以为自己被送进了一家由怪物经营的医院的场景吗？这地方有点像那样。整个地方完全与世隔绝，四周环绕着沼泽。走廊里停着痴呆的病人，流着口水。一个女人不停地走来走去啜泣。中风患者迈克尔似乎站在每个角落，用那种悲伤、空洞的眼神盯着你。而那还是条件较好的一层。
Upstairs are the real basket cases. That's where the howling dwarf lives. We're all afraid to go up there. My mother saw him only once, but you can hear him every night, his voice echoing out into the sawgrass. The only thing worse is the buzzing. God knows why, but the patients' call button in this place isn't a bell or a buzzer like in any normal hospital. It's this.
楼上才是真正的疯人院。那个咆哮的侏儒就住在那里。我们都害怕上去。我母亲只见过他一次，但你每天晚上都能听到他的声音在沼泽草地里回荡。唯一比这更糟糕的是那种嗡嗡声。天知道为什么，这里的病人呼叫按钮不是那种普通医院里的铃声或蜂鸣器。是这个。
[HIGH-PITCHED RINGING]
[高音鸣叫声]
This can go on for 10, 15 minutes straight. An hour, even.
这可以持续10到15分钟。甚至一小时。
[RINGING CONTINUES]
[鸣叫声持续]
Sometimes my mother wakes up in the night to find the buzzer blaring and an orderly asleep in her room. I find it frustrating that she's not more frustrated.
有时我母亲在夜里醒来，发现呼叫器在狂响，而护工在她的房间里睡着了。我觉得她不够沮丧，这让我很抓狂。
Well, as far as the nursing home is concerned, you're sort of stuck there. You might as well make the best of it. At least have a few people you can talk to and--
好吧，就疗养院而言，你算是被困在那里了。不如充分利用它。至少要有几个能说话的人——
But I mean emotionally. I mean, you haven't actually been too upset about your situation, outwardly.
但我指的是情感上。我的意思是，你实际上并没有对自己的处境表现出太多的难过，表面上是这样。
Well, what am I supposed to do Joshua, cry all the time, or throw a fit all the time?
那么，乔书亚，你觉得我该怎么办？一直哭吗，还是一直大吵大闹？
No, I mean, I was glad to see that, in that sense, you were kind of bounced back to normal much faster than I thought. But to me, when I come here-- and for years I'd come here-- and you don't have any idea, but to me and Ethan, this is not normal at all, the way you and David live. It's kind of always like something happens that makes things a little bit worse, and it seems worse, but then you adjust to it, and the sudden that becomes normal. That doesn't ever translate into some kind of action, I guess.
不，我的意思是，看到你在那种意义上恢复得比我预期的要快得多，我很高兴。但对我来说，当我来到这里——多年来我一直来这里——你可能不知道，但在我和伊森看来，这根本不正常，你和大卫的生活方式。总是有什么事情发生，让情况变得更糟一点，看起来更糟了，但你适应了它，突然之间这就变成了常态。我觉得这从来没有转化成任何具体的行动。
Well, it has. And then I put out this great effort, and then I start to lose the energy and I can't get it back. I don't seem to be able to get it back. And I get more and more depressed. I don't know how to explain it. I really don't. If I knew the answers to these questions, Josh, I'd be a very mentally healthy person.
嗯，有过。然后我付出了很大的努力，但我开始失去能量，我无法找回它。我好像找不回它了。我变得越来越抑郁。我不知道该如何解释。我真的不知道。如果我知道这些问题的答案，乔什，我就是一个非常心理健康的人了。
This quality of hers-- this ability to adapt to anything-- is what got her here in the first place. My mom adapted to each new rung on the ladder, and then the next step down didn't seem so bad.
她的这种特质——这种适应任何环境的能力——正是她落到今天这步田地的原因。我妈适应了生活阶梯上的每一个新低点，然后下一步看起来似乎也就没那么糟了。
Take, for example, the hurricane that hit Florida a month before the paramedics came for my mom. As the category five storm was making landfall, David decided to go for a drive. He was pulled over by the cops, which wasn't that surprising since the car had no registration, no insurance, no working tail lights, and a cracked windshield. David, who had no license and maybe had taken some pills to boot, had been pulled over twice already for having that car on the road. He was thrown in jail for a week, and my mother was left all alone.
以我妈送去疗养院前一个月袭击佛罗里达的那场飓风为例。当五级飓风登陆时，大卫决定开车出去。他被警察拦下了，这并不奇怪，因为那辆车没有登记、没有保险、刹车灯坏了、挡风玻璃裂了。大卫没有驾照，而且很可能还吃了一些药，他已经因为开这辆车上路被拦下两次了。他被关进监狱一周，我母亲被独自留在家里。
I mean, I was sitting here in total darkness. There weren't even any streetlights on, you know, wires falling down. Everything was so chaotic. And then, of course, I started drinking out of control, and that was-- I started out saying, I just want a little relief from this insanity, and it made me even more insane.
我的意思是，我坐在这里，周围一片漆黑。连路灯都没有，你知道，电线掉下来。一切都太混乱了。然后，当然，我开始失控地酗酒，那就是——我刚开始说，我只是想从这种疯狂中获得一点解脱，但它让我变得更加疯狂。
How come you didn't call me during that whole period?
在那段时间里，你为什么没打电话给我？
Maybe because I really didn't know what to say, Josh.
也许是因为我真的不知道该说什么，乔什。
Well, I wish I'd have known to come down. I mean, that's-- and then, especially as it got worse, I mean, I wish somebody had called and--
嗯，我真希望那时候能知道回来。我的意思是，那——而且特别是在情况变得更糟的时候，我希望有人打电话，而且——
Yeah, I know.
是啊，我知道。
--Ethan or I could have come out.
——伊森或者我可以过来。
Yeah. Yeah I understand that, Josh, but it's just like--
是啊。是啊，我理解，乔什，但这就像是——
And I'm not-- I wasn't saying that's to make you feel guilty about not calling me. I was just--
而且我不是——我不是为了让你因为没打电话给我而感到内疚。我只是——
No, it's hard to explain. It's just like, you just don't want to intrude into you and Ethan's life and say, one more time, one more time, one more time.
不，这很难解释。就像，你只是不想打扰你和伊森的生活，然后一次又一次地说，再一次，再一次，再一次。
[CRYING]
[哭泣声]
Well, I wouldn't have minded.
嗯，我不会介意的。
Well, I didn't know that.
嗯，我不知道。
I would rather have done that than wind up down here for four months.
我宁愿那样做，也不愿最后在这儿待四个月。
Yeah, I know that. Well, it's part of the whole cycle. It's that you don't want to tell anybody else because if you tell somebody else, then you're telling yourself, which is the last thing you want to do.
是啊，我知道。嗯，这是整个恶性循环的一部分。那就是你不想告诉别人，因为如果你告诉了别人，你就等于在告诉自己，而那是你最不想做的事情。
All right, what are we doing right now?
好了，我们现在在干什么？
Right now we're about to go into the Green Acres Police Station to get a copy of my ticket and police report that I need so I can go sign up for the DUI class.
现在我们正要走进格林阿克斯警察局，去拿那份罚单和警察报告的副本，我需要它以便去报名参加酒驾课程。
This is my brother, David, and we're doing what I do every day down here-- repetitive, exasperating errands, like retrieving a copy of David's DUI charge so he can register for his court-mandated Mothers Against Drunk Driving Victim Impact Panel. This is one of his many conditions for probation. There's a lot of registering for this, reporting for that, retrieving this piece of documentation from that bureaucracy. Everything requires a money order, which, of course, requires money.
这是我弟弟大卫，我们在做我在这里每天都要做的事情——重复、令人恼火的跑腿活，比如取回大卫的酒驾指控副本，这样他才能报名参加法院强制要求的“母亲反对酒驾”(MADD)受害者影响小组。这是他的缓刑条件之一。有太多的报名这个、汇报那个，从官僚机构取回这种文件的活。一切都需要汇款单，而那当然需要钱。
You guys do money orders?
你们这里办汇款单吗？
Yeah. How much?
办。多少钱？
$35.
35美元。
That'll be $36.
总共是36美元。
$36?
36美元？
Do I have to pay that?
我一定要付这个吗？
Yeah. I don't have $36. I don't have $5.
是的。我没有36美元。我连5美元都没有。
Riding along for David's probationary checklist, it's easy to see how the downward spiral works. Fail to turn in one piece of paper, and next time you have to show up with two more. Miss a date, and your probation is longer. And that means paying extra to the court for the extended supervision, which means borrowing money, or pawning something, or wiring money, all of which come with huge fees. And David knows this better than anybody.
经历大卫的缓刑清单跑腿，很容易看出这种向下螺旋是如何运作的。少交一份文件，下次你就得带着两份出现。错过一个日期，你的缓刑期就更长。这意味着要向法院支付额外的延长监督费，这意味着借钱、典当东西或者汇款，所有这些都带有高额费用。大卫比任何人都清楚这一点。
When you're breaking the law, you just watch your money decrease more and more. And not to mention, it's like three, four years ago-- even in 2004, two years ago-- I was doing my thing in the studio. I was getting music done. I was taking care of what I needed to do with that. And since I got off that path and just starting getting all these stupid little charges and [BLEEP], it takes away from my time to do anything. And you don't exactly feel too creative when you're behind bars. They want to try to say that they're going to rehabilitate you, but they don't know what's wrong with you to begin with to rehabilitate that anyway, you know?
当你触犯法律时，你只能看着你的钱越来越少。更不用说，三四年前——甚至2004年，两年前——我还在工作室里做我的事。我正在完成音乐创作。我正在处理我需要做的事情。自从我偏离了那条轨道，开始收到所有这些愚蠢的小指控和鬼东西，它就占用了我做任何事的时间。当你被关在牢里时，你感觉不到什么创造力。他们想要声称他们要改造你，但他们甚至根本不知道你有什么问题，怎么去改造它，你知道吗？
Right. I mean, rehabilitation involves all kinds of complicated stuff. Figuring out--
对。我的意思是，改造涉及各种复杂的事情。搞清楚——
What's wrong with you.
你有什么问题。
--why you haven't been holding down a job, or why you keep screwing around, and then helping out once you get out, like I've been doing.
——为什么你一直找不到稳定的工作，或者为什么你一直乱搞，然后等你出来后再提供帮助，就像我一直在做的那样。
Right. Exactly. Like if I didn't have all this help now that I have, it would have been a lot easier-- not saying that I necessarily would have, but it would definitely have been a lot easier to just fall back into that like, well, what's the point of trying type [BLEEP], you know? Because there's nothing to look forward to. There's no way out, so you're like, [BLEEP] it.
对。完全正确。就像如果我现在没有所有这些帮助，那会容易得多——不是说我一定会那样做，但肯定会更容易陷入那种“努力有什么意义”的鬼想法，你知道吗？因为没有什么可期待的。没有出路，所以你就像，去他妈的。
It's a powerful force, that gravitational pull of downward mobility, because, if you think about it, David really shouldn't be that bad off. He can hold down a job. And he's not a bad rapper, either. He has dozens of notebooks filled with lyrics, and he's even recorded some songs. He's also really funny. Here he is talking about his latest job at the Village Diner, a blue-plate special place that was just outside the gates of Century Village, and where, every day, a busload of regulars would arrive on the noon shuttle for lunch.
向下流动性有一种强大的力量，因为它那种引力太强了，因为如果你仔细想想，大卫真的不应该过得这么惨。他可以维持一份工作。他也不是个差劲的说唱歌手。他有几十本写满歌词的笔记本，甚至录过一些歌。他也很风趣。这是他在村庄餐厅工作的谈话，那是一家位于世纪村大门外的小餐馆，每天中午班车上都会载来一车常客。
There was this guy, Big Balls-- well, he would just come in every single day, faithfully, and he'd order the same thing, which was meatloaf, a side of chicken noodle soup, and chocolate ice cream. I still remember. Every single day.
有个叫“大蛋蛋”的家伙——他每天都会忠实地进来，点的东西都一样，那就是肉饼、一碗鸡汤面和巧克力冰淇淋。我还记得。每一天都这样。
But if you walked up like-- you'd want to fill out his ticket already because you already knew what he was ordering. So you'd start writing it, and he'd be like, so what's the special today? And so you'd run through it anyway, knowing damn well that, at the end, he's still just going to say, let me get the meatloaf. And he always seemed surprised when he did it, too. He'd be thinking for a second. Let me get the meatloaf-- every single time. And you'd have to just humor him because there was a couple times when I was like, I know you want the usual. And he's like, wait, wait.
但如果你走过去就像——你想直接帮他填好订单，因为你知道他要点什么。所以你会开始写，他会说，今天的特色菜是什么？于是你无论如何还是会背一遍，明明知道他最后还是会说，给我肉饼。而且他每次点的时候似乎都很惊讶。他会思考一秒钟。给我肉饼——每次都这样。你只能迁就他，因为有几次我说，我知道你要点老样子。他就说，等等，等等。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Good afternoon, doctor's office.
下午好，医生办公室。
Hi. I wanted to inquire about a letter that I requested from Dr. Thompson regarding my mother, a former patient of his.
嗨。我想咨询一下我要求汤普森医生开的一封关于我母亲的信，她是他的一位前病人。
Meanwhile, my mom's $100,000 hospital bill finally showed up. This is on top of the mounting nursing home expenses. And the only way she can pay for all of it is if I get her on Medicaid and/or Social Security disability, which means tracking down records for every doctor she's ever had.
同时，我妈妈那张10万美元的医院账单终于到了。这是在不断增加的疗养院费用之上的额外负担。她支付这一切的唯一方法是让我帮她申请医疗补助和/或社会保障残疾福利，这意味着要搜集她看过的每位医生的记录。
Then there's the fact that my mother is my mother. Like some kind of tragic supervillain who can't control her destructive powers, my mother somehow leaves an accidental trail of carnage wherever she goes.
还有个事实，我妈妈就是我妈妈。就像某个无法控制其破坏力的悲剧超级反派，我母亲无论走到哪里，都会留下意外的伤痕。
Mailbox 1. You have 21 old messages. [BEEP]
信箱1。你有21条旧留言。[哔]
Allied Interstate calling in regards to an important personal matter that was described in a letter to you. Due to federal and ethical state statutes, no further information may be left. This is not a solicitation.
Allied Interstate来电，关于信中提到的重要个人事项。由于联邦和州伦理法规，无法留下更多信息。这不是推销电话。
In this case, it seems that my mom ran into a car, gave the woman driving outdated insurance information, and then left the scene before police showed up. I'd found a letter from the woman and her attorney in the trash, unopened. This is typical of my mother's approach. She doesn't want to confront her problems, and she finds very particular ways of avoiding them.
在这种情况下，似乎我妈撞了一辆车，给了开车的那位女士过期的保险信息，然后还没等警察到场就离开了现场。我在垃圾桶里发现了那位女士和她律师寄来的一封信，没拆封。这是我母亲解决问题的典型方法。她不想面对自己的问题，她会用非常独特的方式回避它们。
Yeah, I really don't know the layout of this place. Apparel is this way.
是啊，我真不知道这个地方的布局。服装部往这边走。
Every time I call now, my mother demands that I take her shopping. Each day, there's a strangely specific new request-- flip-flops, costume jewelry, hair dye, lottery tickets. When I call to get the name of her neurologist, she wants to know if I picked up the socks she asked for.
现在每次我打电话，我母亲都要求我带她去购物。每天都有一个奇怪的具体新要求——人字拖、廉价首饰、染发剂、彩票。当我打电话问她神经科医生的名字时，她想知道我有没有买她要求的袜子。
I told you I'd take you to Walmart eventually.
我告诉过你我会带你去沃尔玛的。
Yeah, right.
是啊，好吧。
Why were you dying to get here?
你为什么急着来这儿？
I know. Because I need those-- I need a couple-- I need jeans.
我知道。因为我需要那些——我需要几条——我需要牛仔裤。
I think I understand the shopping. My mom doesn't have much control in her life-- no car, no money-- and so buying jean shorts is a goal she can handle. And in Walmart, there's no tragic past or scary future. She's just a customer in the unburdened present. And so we go to Target, Walgreens, and the Dollar Store.
我想我明白了。我妈在生活中没什么掌控权——没车、没钱——所以买牛仔短裤是她能完成的一个目标。在沃尔玛，没有悲剧的过去或可怕的未来。她只是一个无忧无虑的普通顾客。所以我们就去塔吉特、沃尔格林和美元店。
One day, I find myself entering a strip mall with the following to-do list. One carton of Marlboro 100s, a 12-pack of [INAUDIBLE] adult diapers, and a jar of herring packed in cream.
有一天，我发现自己走进一家带购物清单的带状商场。一盒万宝路100香烟，一打成人纸尿裤，还有一罐奶油腌鲱鱼。
My friend Starlee is visiting me in Florida, and she can see that it's getting to me. Starlee-- her voice might be familiar because she's done stories on This American Life before-- comes with me on yet another errand, and we discuss my mother's endless to-do list.
我的朋友斯塔莉正在佛罗里达探望我，她看出这让我很抓狂。斯塔莉——她的声音你可能很熟悉，因为她以前做过《美国生活》的故事——和我一起去办又一件差事，我们讨论了我母亲没完没了的待办事项。
Last week it was the phone card. We had to get a phone card. We drove all these different places looking for a phone card. And she had a phone card before I got here. And I was saying, well, where did you get that phone card? Wherever you got that one, get it from them! I don't want to drive around and find you a phone card all over Palm Beach County with this. It takes a half an hour between 7-Elevens to get-- it's all so time consuming, and U-turns, and nobody knows where it is.
上周是电话卡。我们要买一张电话卡。我们开车去了所有这些不同的地方找电话卡。我到这儿之前她就有张电话卡。我当时说，好吧，你那是从哪儿买的？在哪儿买的就回哪儿买！我不想为了这个在整个棕榈滩县开车到处找电话卡。在各个7-Eleven之间跑要花半小时——这太耗时了，还要掉头，而且没人知道在哪儿买。
We went to three different places. They didn't have the right phone card. And then we went to one place and she's like, no, I don't want that one. That's not the cheap one. And then we got the phone card, and you know how much-- what the amount of the phone card was that we spent all this time? $5.
我们去了三个不同的地方。他们都没有那种电话卡。然后我们去了第四个地方，她说，不，我不要那个。那不是便宜的。然后我们终于买到了，你知道我们要买的那种花了我们这么多时间的电话卡值多少钱吗？5美元。
It lasted $5 worth of minutes?
那张卡只有5美元的通话时间？
Yeah, she bought only $5 worth of minutes. She said this is the cheap one. It's plenty of minutes on here.
对，她只买了5美元的通话时间。她说这是便宜的。上面有很多分钟。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
I don't know what to do.
我不知道该怎么办。
I mean, there's a huge-- the thing is that it's not like you come to get her and she's like, let's go to the beach today. I feel I need to be out with the living at the beach, or at the movies, or going to work on something productive in my life-- not like that. It's all the errands revolve around the stuff she needs to take back to this weird place that she now lives. It's like there was never a time before the home, all of the sudden.
我的意思是，巨大的问题在于，并不是说你带她出来，她会说，咱们今天去海边吧。我觉得我需要去海边和活着的人待在一起，或者去看电影，或者去处理我生活中一些有意义的事情——不是这样。所有的跑腿活都围绕着她需要带回那个她现在居住的怪地方的东西。就好像在养老院之前从来没有过其他时间一样。
I know.
我知道。
It's weird, right?
很怪，对吧？
But also, compared to the other people in that place-- the rest of the cast of Jacob's Ladder in there-- she looks like she's literally in the administration. I mean, she hangs around with the administrators and the social workers. And she hangs out with them and talks to them, like what are we gonna do about this case that we've got here? And she's totally high-functioning and in on all the decisions about what did you do with the VCR and what's going on with Michael's family? Are they coming today or not? We gotta get him ready.
但相比那个地方里的其他人——《雅各布的阶梯》里的其他演员——她看起来简直是在行政部门。我是说，她和管理人员、社会工作者待在一起。她和他们闲逛，跟他们聊天，就像在讨论我们手头的这个案子该怎么办？她完全有行为能力，并参与了所有决策，比如录像机怎么处理，迈克尔的家人怎么样了？他们今天来吗？我们得准备好他。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
The problem is that, while my mother is obsessing with the small things, there are big things we need to do, like, for example, figure out a plan for her. She can't stay at the nursing home because it's too expensive and depressing. She can't go back to Century Village because she'd be alone and could easily start drinking again. I'd like her to go into some kind of long-term treatment center, but whenever I talk to her about it, she has her own plans.
问题是，当我母亲沉迷于小事时，我们有大事需要做，比如，为她制定一个计划。她不能呆在疗养院，因为太贵且让人沮丧。她不能回到世纪村，因为她会孤身一人，很容易再次开始喝酒。我希望她去某种长期治疗中心，但每当我跟她谈起这件事，她都有自己的计划。
I was going to go up north-- remember we discussed this-- for a few months. And then I'm going to come back here.
我打算去北方——记得我们讨论过这个——待几个月。然后再回来这儿。
So your plan is-- I mean, do you think that you'd be better off back here?
所以你的计划是——我是说，你认为回到这里会更好吗？
Yeah, for a time.
是啊，待一段时间。
I mean, I'm asking because, when we moved you in here, Ethan and I, we did that because that made the most practical sense in the short-term, but we were both worried that exactly what happened was going to happen. And you were saying, oh, things are going to be fine. And they weren't fine. They were disastrous to the tune of $100,000 now, maybe.
我是问这个问题是因为，当初我和伊森送你进去时，是因为短期内那样做最合理，但我们都担心会发生现在这样的事情。而你说，噢，情况会好的。结果并不好。它们是灾难性的，损失现在可能达到10万美元。
Right, right. No, that's true. But I'm done with the alcohol, Josh. I really am. It kicked my ass so bad this time, physical and emotional.
对，对。不，那是真的。但我已经戒酒了，乔什。我真的戒了。这次它在身心上都把我折磨得够呛。
Are you sure? I mean, that's what I want to know. That's what I feel like I need to know.
你确定吗？我的意思是，那是我想要知道的。我觉得我需要知道这个。
I don't want to go through that pain ever again. Never.
我再也不想经历那种痛苦了。永远不想。
Hello, Regan. I'm Damien Karras.
你好，里根。我是达米恩·卡拉斯。
And I'm the devil! Now kindly undo these straps!
而我是魔鬼！现在赶紧松开这些带子！
There's this one small, but telling, moment in the movie The Exorcist that's always reminded me of my mother.
电影《驱魔人》里有一个细微但发人深省的时刻，总是让我想起我母亲。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语对话]
It's when the devil, through Regan, the possessed girl, is pretending to be Father Karras' dead mother.
那是当魔鬼借用被附身的女孩里根之口，假装成卡拉斯神父已故的母亲时。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语对话]
She speaks to him softly in Greek, and he wants to believe it. You can see his face overcome with emotion, missing her, regretting, and resisting, because he knows it's not his mother. It's a demon. And it's the kind of acting job that all alcoholics can turn out at will. There have been times when my brother, Ethan, and I have had to prepare to talk to my mother the same way that Max von Sydow warns Father Karras before they enter Regan's room.
她用希腊语轻声对他说话，他想要相信。你能看到他脸上被情绪淹没，想念她，感到后悔，同时又在抵抗，因为他知道那不是他的母亲。那是恶魔。这是所有酗酒者都能随心所欲演出的那种戏码。有些时候，我和弟弟伊森不得不准备好，以马克斯·冯·叙多夫在进入里根房间前警告卡拉斯神父的那种方式，来应对我母亲。
He's a liar. The demon is a liar. He will like to confuse us. But he will also mix lies with the truth to attack us. The attack is psychological, Damien, and powerful. So don't listen to him. Remember that. Do not listen.
他是骗子。恶魔是个骗子。他会试图迷惑我们。但他也会把谎言和真相混在一起攻击我们。这种攻击是心理上的，且威力强大。所以不要听他的。记住这一点。不要听。
Doesn't it frustrate you that your mom never acts like your mom?
你妈从不像你妈一样行事，你不感到沮丧吗？
Yeah. Yeah. It's a really horrible feeling, actually, to feel like your mom is lying to you, and that you can't trust anything she says, and that you have to guard yourself against everything, and that you can't-- like now, she says that this is the worst, and I don't want to feel that pain again, and I really want to go in there with her and sympathize. But I absolutely have to-- I learned a long time ago you cannot. You can't because that's when you're susceptible to--
是啊。是啊。真的感觉很糟糕，实际上，觉得你妈妈在对你撒谎，你不能相信她说的话，你必须对一切保持警惕，而且你不能——就像现在，她说这是最糟糕的，我再也不想感受那种痛苦了，我真的很想进去同情她。但我绝对必须——我很久以前就学到了你不能。你不能，因为那时你会容易受到——
The demon.
魔鬼的伤害。
To the demon. And the demon wants to go to Minnesota now. And I don't know if the demon should go to Minnesota. I want to let the demon go to Minnesota. I want to untie her from the bed and let her free, but then she's going to throw me out the window.
受到魔鬼的伤害。而魔鬼现在想去明尼苏达。我不知道魔鬼该不该去明尼苏达。我想让魔鬼去明尼苏达。我想把她从床上解开，让她自由，但接下来她会把我从窗户扔出去。
The thing is, you would like nothing more than to say-- it'd be a relief for her to just go to Minnesota, probably.
问题是，你最希望说的就是——让她去明尼苏达，可能是一种解脱。
It would be a relief.
那会是一种解脱。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, coming up, Josh's mom starts talking to him in Greek, so to speak. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
好了，接下来，乔什的妈妈开始用希腊语跟他对话，可以这么说。稍后节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, a story that we first ran back in 2007, about Joshuah Bearman and the family duty that he found himself trying to fulfill. When we left off before the break, his mom was still in a nursing home. His half-brother, David, was trying to get his life together and stay out of jail. Josh picks up the story from there.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，一个我们在2007年首次播出的故事，关于乔书亚·贝尔曼和他试图履行的家庭责任。休息前我们讲到，他妈妈还在疗养院。他的同母异父弟弟大卫正在试图整理自己的生活，远离监狱。乔什从这里继续讲述。
Time can be merciless in South Florida. It's easy for a numbing routine to develop down here, which is exactly what happens as I spend countless hours Xeroxing medical records and driving 40 miles to fix the kitchen sink because David can't quite figure out how to operate the plumber's wrench. Every time there's progress on some small thing, I look up and realize the horizon is still miles away.
在南佛罗里达，时间是无情的。在这里，麻木的常规很容易形成，而这正是我花费无数时间复印医疗记录，并开车40英里去修理厨房水槽时所发生的事情，因为大卫搞不懂怎么用管钳。每当小事有一点进展，我抬头看时，才发现地平线依然遥不可及。
But at least my mom hasn't been drinking. I was sure that, as soon as she could walk, she'd take the pocket cash I gave her each week and convince someone to smuggle booze into the nursing home. It really wouldn't be that hard. This is a woman who could figure out how to get hooch if she were trapped in Apollo 13. But she's resisted so far, which means one less thing to worry about. It also means I can talk to her without the sway of alcohol clouding every conversation. I can ask her questions that would have been impossible before, like how exactly did this all begin?
但至少我妈妈没在喝酒了。我确信，只要她能走路，她就会拿我每周给她的零花钱，说服某人走私酒进疗养院。那真的不难。这是一个如果被困在阿波罗13号上也能想出办法弄到酒的女人。但到目前为止她还没这样做，这意味着少了一件担心的事。这也意味着我可以在没有酒精干扰对话的情况下跟她交谈。我可以问她以前不可能问的问题，比如这到底是怎么开始的？
You know, it's hardly like I woke up one day and said, gee, I'd like to become an alcoholic. And there was absolutely no question that it was brought on by my post-traumatic stress disorder. Flashbacks of the scenario in Minneapolis, vivid, like I was experiencing it all over again.
你知道，我可不是哪天醒来就说，嘿，我想成为一个酒鬼。毫无疑问，这完全是由我的创伤后应激障碍引起的。明尼苏达那场情景的回忆，太生动了，就像我正身临其境一样。
The scenario in Minneapolis? That's another big part of the story-- one that I haven't told you about yet. Part of the reason for my parents' messy divorce was that, when my dad left for his NASA job, my mom was supposed to stay behind, finish up our school year, sell the house, and meet him in Pasadena. Instead, she met a man named Sonny at a Minneapolis nightclub.
明尼苏达的情景？那是故事的另一个重要部分——我还没来得及告诉你。我父母婚姻混乱的部分原因是，当我爸爸离开去NASA工作时，我妈妈本应该留下来，完成我们的学年，卖掉房子，在帕萨迪纳和他汇合。相反，她在明尼阿波利斯的一家夜总会遇到了一个叫桑尼的人。
He was a Cherokee, six-foot-five and lean, charming but moody, and often carrying his guitar. He was the very opposite of my father. Sonny moved in, and my mother never made it to Pasadena.
他是切罗基人，身高六英尺五英寸，精瘦，迷人但喜怒无常，经常带着他的吉他。他和我父亲完全相反。桑尼搬了进来，我母亲再也没去成帕萨迪纳。
Sonny was also a drug dealer. Sometimes his friends would fill the house, partying full steam and staying up late. I remember being babysat by Sonny's stoned Sioux friends, showing them my dinosaur dioramas and trying to convince them to play Dungeons and Dragons with me. I'm not sure what my mother was after, but she loved Sonny, and my father was heartbroken. And so after my parents' divorce, Ethan and I went back and forth for a while-- a year in California, a year in Minnesota.
桑尼也是个毒贩。有时他的朋友会挤满房子，尽情狂欢，熬夜到很晚。我记得被桑尼那些嗑药的苏族朋友照看着，向他们展示我的恐龙立体模型，试图说服他们和我一起玩《龙与地下城》。我不确定我母亲当时在追求什么，但她爱桑尼，而我父亲心碎了。所以父母离婚后，我和伊森轮流两边跑——在加州住一年，在明尼苏达住一年。
It was around then that that photograph was taken-- the one I found in my mother's bedroom after she was rushed to the hospital. It's actually a picture of her and Sonny together. My mom is dressed up, yellow lapel points flaring out over a black dress. Sonny is wearing a tan suit. They're on a couch together, both facing the camera. It's my mother's favorite photo from those days.
那张照片就是那时候拍的——我妈被紧急送往医院后，我在她卧室里发现的那张。实际上那是她和桑尼的合影。我妈穿着盛装，黄色翻领在黑色连衣裙上闪现。桑尼穿着棕色西装。他们坐在一起，都面对镜头。那是妈妈那段日子里最喜欢的照片。
How old was I there? 30? Yeah. In fact, I know it was 30 because it was in August, and it was his 40th birthday, and I was three months pregnant with David. It was a happy time. I remember how good I felt then. I also remember how much I missed feeling like that, enjoying things, just being in love, and all those things. Do you remember  when we used to go to the Nature Center, all of us? We'd go with Sonny to Richfield Nature Center?
我那时多大？30？是的。实际上我知道是30岁，因为是在八月，那是他40岁生日，我怀大卫三个月。那是一段快乐的时光。我记得那时我感觉有多好。我也记得我有多怀念那种感觉，享受事物，仅仅是坠入爱河，还有所有那些事情。你记得我们以前一起去自然中心吗？我们和桑尼一起去里奇菲尔德自然中心？
No, I don't remember that.
不，我不记得那个。
And then I would be coming down the walk, and you guys would jump out at me and try and scare me?
然后我会走下来，你们会跳出来吓我？
I remember that.
我记得那个。
That was at the Nature Center.
那是自然中心。
I remember just doing that always.
我记得总是那么做。
Always, yeah. Right.
总是，是啊。对。
Like in the grocery store and wherever.
比如在杂货店和别的地方。
Someone recently asked me if I love my mother, and I realized I actually had to think about it. I do, of course, but for months I've seen her only as a set of problems. It's often hard to remember the person my mother once was when she enrolled at Cornell at 16, spoke French, and got a master's degree. When she was lucid, I used to like hearing her stories about growing up with my grandparents and their exploits in pre-war Palestine, or talking about the news, since she was always intensely political.
有人最近问我是否爱我母亲，我意识到我真的得思考一下。我当然爱她，但几个月来，我只把她看作一堆问题。当母亲在16岁进入康奈尔大学、说法语、拿到硕士学位时，很难记住她曾经的样子。当她清醒时，我喜欢听她讲关于和祖父母一起长大的故事，以及他们在战前巴勒斯坦的经历，或者谈论新闻，因为她一直非常热衷政治。
I hadn't seen much of that old self on this trip to Florida. And then one evening, I took my mother to dinner at Red Lobster. It must have put her in some kind of good mood because, while we were going over the menu, she starts telling me some story, a tiny episode from my childhood, a little glimpse of what it was like before all this. And I can't even remember what it was other than it flooded me with the sudden, overwhelming realization that this person across from me actually is my mother and that if things had been different, we could have been getting dinner together like normal people.
在这次佛罗里达之行中，我没怎么看到那个旧的她。然后有一天晚上，我带母亲去红龙虾餐厅吃饭。这一定让她心情不错，因为当我们翻看菜单时，她开始给我讲故事，关于我童年的一个小片段，一点点对这一切发生之前的 glimpse。我甚至不记得那是什么，除了它让我突然意识到，坐在我对面的人确实是我的母亲，如果一切都不同的话，我们本可以像正常人一样一起吃晚饭。
And when I start crying right there, at 4:30 PM at the Red Lobster on Okeechobee Boulevard, my mother tries to comfort me, like mothers do, for the first time in as long as I can remember. I wish things were different, I say. I wish they were, too, she answers.
当我下午4点半在奥基乔比大道的红龙虾餐厅开始哭泣时，我母亲试着安慰我，像母亲应该做的那样，这是我记得的最久的一次。我希望一切有所不同，我说。我希望也是，她回答。
It's hard to say exactly how the woman I remember from childhood became the one sitting with me today. But there's no question a lot of it had to do with that scenario in Minneapolis, which was this one night when some strangers showed up at the house.
很难确切说，我童年记忆中的女人是怎么变成今天坐在我面前的这个人的。但毫无疑问，很大程度上与明尼苏达的那一幕有关，那是一个晚上，一些陌生人出现在门口。
And these people came to the door and told me that they were having car trouble, asked me if my husband was home, and did we have jumper cables. And it all seemed legit to me because I couldn't get my car started that day. It was really, really cold. So they wanted to use the phone, which sounded logical, although there was a payphone on the corner, and I should have told them to go there or asked them for the number and never let them in the house. What I should have done and what I did do are two different things.
这些人来到门口，告诉我有车出了毛病，问我丈夫在家吗，有没有跨接电缆。这对我来说似乎很合理，因为那天我发动不了车。天气真的非常、非常冷。所以他们想用电话，这听起来合逻辑，虽然街角有公用电话，我本应该告诉他们去那儿或者问他们号码，绝不让他们进屋。我本应该做的和我所做的，是两码事。
So anyway, they came in and they were-- they must have heard him coming up the pathway, because the snow was packed on the walkway. He came in, and that's when the guy puts a gun to my hip and told him, don't come any further. I'm going to blow this bitch away.
总之，他们进来了，他们是——他们一定听到了他在走道上走过来，因为雪在小路上压得很紧。他进来了，就在那时，那家伙把枪抵在我的腰上，告诉他，别再往前了。我要毙了这个贱人。
I was there that night, too. I actually answered the door. I remember how cold it was when the couple came inside. I didn't see him, but outside was a third man. There's always a third man at a hit, the police later said, but I didn't know what was happening. I was in the other room, watching CHiPs with David, when Sonny came home and drew his own 9 millimeter. I heard gunfire, and looked up to see bullets coming through the walls near David. I took him out of his high chair, hid in the bathroom, and watched the hitman out the window, running off past the icicles in the alley.
那天晚上我也在场。实际上是我开了门。我记得那对夫妇进来时有多冷。我没看到他，但外面有第三个人。警察后来总是说，暗杀总有第三个人，但我不知道发生了什么。我和大卫在另一个房间看《警匪情缘》时，桑尼回到家，拔出了他自己的9毫米手枪。我听到了枪声，抬头看到子弹穿过大卫附近的墙。我把他从高脚椅里抱出来，躲进浴室，从窗户看到杀手逃跑经过小巷里的冰柱。
In the other room, Sonny was down. My mother was so frantic she couldn't remember his name when she called 911. I had to get on the line and explain to the paramedics where we lived. I was nine-- or I would be the next day. A few weeks later, Sonny died in the hospital. That's why my father got full custody of me and Ethan. David was Sonny's kid, so he stayed with my mother.
在另一个房间里，桑尼倒下了。我母亲慌乱得打电话报警时连他的名字都记不起来。我得接通电话，向护理人员解释我们住在哪儿。那时我九岁——或者第二天就是九岁了。几周后，桑尼在医院去世了。这就是为什么我父亲获得了我和伊森的完全监护权。大卫是桑尼的孩子，所以他和母亲待在一起。
We saw them during summer for a few years, but things were never the same. I don't even remember the turning point, but eventually she stopped working, and we stopped going. I've always assumed that those missing years were rough for my mother and David, but while in Florida, I discovered that they were worse than I thought.
我们有几年夏天会见到他们，但事情再也不一样了。我甚至不记得转折点是什么，但最终她停止了工作，我们也不再去了。我一直以为那缺失的几年对我母亲和大卫来说很艰苦，但在佛罗里达期间，我发现它们比我想象的更糟。
So I need to find a bunch of records in here. They must have stored boxes.
我得在里面找一堆记录。他们肯定存了盒子。
One day, back in the condo, I'm searching for some medical documents. Surprisingly, my mother's effects are pretty well organized, fitting mostly in one small, gunmetal file case. It occurs to me, flipping through, that there's not much in it because not much has happened to my mother. Her entire life fits in this little box.
有一天，在公寓里，我搜索一些医疗文件。令人惊讶的是，我母亲的私人物品整理得相当好，大多装在一个小小的、铁灰色文件盒里。翻阅时我想到，里面没多少东西，因为我母亲没发生过什么事。她的一生都塞进这个小盒子里了。
This is something addressed to my mom, 1985. Des Moines Child Guidance Center. Oh, this is about David. "I saw David Parks, age four, on May 22, 1985, after you had referred him to the Des Moines Child Guidance Center at the suggestion of Candace Bennett of juvenile court." Well, that's crazy. How can you be involved in court at age four?
这是1985年寄给我妈的。得梅因儿童指导中心。噢，这是关于大卫的。“我在1985年5月22日见到了4岁的大卫·帕克斯，这是在你根据少年法庭的坎迪斯·贝内特的建议，把他转介给得梅因儿童指导中心之后。”天哪，这太疯狂了。你怎么会在4岁时就卷入法庭纠纷？
Well, here it says, "this was following an escapade in which David stole money out of your purse, wandered away from home, and told the police that he was going to the store to buy some food because his mother had not fed him breakfast. When I saw David, he was living with you but had recently been in a foster home for about a week, or 10 days, while you were in the hospital."
嗯，这里说，“这是一次冒险之后，大卫从你的钱包里偷了钱，从家里溜走，告诉警察他要去商店买食物，因为他妈妈没让他吃早餐。我见到大卫时，他和你住在一起，但最近在寄养家庭待过一周或10天，当时你在医院。”
Huh. I didn't know David was ever in a foster home. That poor kid. And I didn't know that she was in the hospital in 1985. I didn't quite realize things were that bad that early.
哈。我不知道大卫还被寄养过。那个可怜的孩子。我也不知道她在1985年住过院。我没意识到情况在那时就已经那么糟了。
A few days later, I bring up those missing years with David. For the first time, I get a clearer picture of what life was like for him, living with a grieving mother who was drinking more and more, and getting caught up with a string of abusive men.
几天后，我和大卫谈起了那些缺失的岁月。我第一次更清楚地了解了他与一个哀伤、酗酒且卷入一系列虐待男人的母亲共同生活是什么样。
They weren't good people. I mean, they weren't the worst people in the world, either. But they all were in and out of jail, beating up Mom, threatening to kill her, threatening to kill me. Like at 14 years old or something, I was thrown into the glass china cabinet that Mom had by her boyfriend, Mark. And he was so drunk, I ended up fighting him that night and finally I restrained him to this chair.
他们不是好人。我的意思是，他们也不是世界上最糟糕的人。但他们都进进出出监狱，殴打妈妈，威胁要杀她，威胁要杀我。大概14岁左右，我被妈妈的男朋友马克扔进了她那个玻璃瓷器柜。他喝得太醉了，那天晚上我最后跟他打了一架，最终把他制服在椅子上。
It's a weird feeling when you're that young and you've got to stick up for your mother because you're the only-- you are the man of the household. And if you don't stand up for that, then all this other crazy [BLEEP] is going to happen. And having cops called to the house all the time, and then watching her, because she had feelings for him, tell the cops, oh, nothing is happening, or hide him out and [BLEEP] like that.
当你那么年轻，必须为你妈妈出头，因为你是家中唯一的男人，这种感觉很怪。如果你不站出来，那所有其他疯狂的鬼东西就会发生。家里总是叫警察，然后看着她，因为她对他有感情，告诉警察，噢，什么都没发生，或者把他藏起来之类的。
And you, at that age, when you're going through all that, you know it's not right, so you try to act your life isn't bad. You try to act like your life is normal. You hide all that away from the rest of the world. I was scared to have people-- friends of mine-- come over and sleep over at the house because the average kid is going to be freaked out.
你在这个年纪，经历着这一切，你知道这不对，所以你试图假装你的生活没那么糟。你试图表现得像你的生活很正常。你把这一切从世界上掩盖起来。我害怕让我的朋友过来在家里过夜，因为普通孩子会被吓坏。
You try to warn them ahead of time like, look, this situation is grim. You're going to hear [BLEEP] you aren't supposed to hear. You're going to see [BLEEP] that you definitely shouldn't be seeing at this age. And it's real. It's right there in front of you. Cops might be called. Violent acts might occur around you. You've just got to-- you know, you're like a soldier. And so then the kids that do end up coming over that become regulars are the ones just as [BLEEP]-up as you.
你试图提前警告他们，看，情况很糟糕。你会听到不该听的鬼东西。你会看到在这个年纪绝对不该看到的东西。这是真的。它就在你面前。可能会叫警察。你周围可能会发生暴力行为。你只是不得不——你知道，你就像个士兵。所以最后过来的常客都是和你一样烂透了的家伙。
We went up to this cabin up north, me and this kid named Kenny, who was the son of Kenny, Sr., who was Mark's friend. So they're all drinking. And they put some bottles up on this old truck that's all gutted out or whatever. And there was a competition between me and Kenny on who-- we took a .22 rifle, and who could knock down the most bottles. And I guess they might have put money on the whole thing, whatever. We're in the middle of nowhere, up north Minnesota, close to the Canadian border.
我们去过北方的一个小屋，我和一个叫肯尼的孩子，他是老肯尼的儿子，那是马克的死党。所以他们都在喝酒。他们把瓶子放在一辆破旧的卡车上，那是 gutted 的车之类的。我和肯尼之间有一场比赛，看谁——我们拿了一把.22口径步枪，看谁能打掉最多的瓶子。我猜他们可能在整个过程中赌了钱，什么的。我们在明尼苏达北方的荒郊野外，靠近加拿大边境。
So I ended up winning the competition because I was always a good shot. And Kenny, Jr., ended up getting beat by his father because I won. Because that [BLEEP] was so important to them that his son was now a pansy or whatever, because he didn't beat me.
所以最后是我赢了比赛，因为我枪法一直很好。小肯尼最后被他父亲打了，因为我赢了。因为那种鬼东西对他们来说太重要了，他的儿子现在是个懦夫之类的，因为他没赢我。
David also provided some new details to the story about Sonny. Mom likes to downplay Sonny's drug dealing, although, during one of our conversations, she did let slip that, well, OK, maybe there was cocaine in the house when Sonny was killed, and that she cleverly hid this cocaine from the cops by throwing it in David's diaper hamper. And then David adds this.
大卫还提供了一些关于桑尼故事的新细节。妈妈喜欢淡化桑尼的毒品交易，尽管在我们的一次谈话中，她确实说漏了嘴，好吧，没关系，桑尼被杀时房子里可能确实有可卡因，而且她聪明地把这些可卡因藏在了大卫的尿布篓里。大卫又补充了这一点。
He was selling cocaine-- I mean, living the gangster lifestyle, and not just normal gangster lifestyle. He used to have a passport, going to all these countries and smuggling drugs and jewels and [BLEEP]. Not just your like small-time around-the-block.
他在卖可卡因——我的意思是，过着黑帮生活，而且不仅仅是普通的黑帮生活。他以前有护照，去所有这些国家走私毒品和珠宝之类的东西。不仅仅是你那种街头小打小闹。
Wait, wait, wait. What's with the passport? I never heard about the fake passport.
等等，等等，等等。护照是怎么回事？我从来没听说过伪造护照。
No, it was a real passport. He went to all these countries like Malaysia, Thailand, India, Pakistan. And he used to go there-- and this was back in times when you had a false bottom in the suitcase, and he would smuggle back, with his brother-- my uncle--
不，那是真护照。他去过所有这些国家，比如马来西亚、泰国、印度、巴基斯坦。以前在那个年代，你会在手提箱里弄个假底层，他和他的兄弟——我的叔叔——
Larry.
拉里。
Yeah. They would smuggle back drugs and jewels and things like that. Matter of fact, my grandmother on my father's side was working in a bank, and she used to launder some of their money.
是啊。他们会走私毒品和珠宝之类的东西回来。事实上，我父亲那边的祖母在银行工作，她以前帮他们洗钱。
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Wait, so--
哇，哇，哇。等等，所以——
You never heard all this?
你从没听说过这一切？
No, I never-- I never heard about the Cherokee drug-smuggling, money-laundering operation.
不，我从没听说过什么切罗基走私毒品、洗钱行动。
It's startling to compare David's life at this time-- the life I could have had-- with the life I actually did have in Pasadena with my father. Things weren't perfect there, I should say. As a teenager, I started fighting with my dad enough that I moved out at 16. I spent a summer working at Pizza Hut in Ontario, California, sharing a house with meth heads. But the difference is that my dad gave me perspective. I knew what was normal. We'd had regular bedtimes, built model rockets, and went to art class on Saturday mornings. I always expected I'd go to college. Even at that dingy Pizza Hut, I'd sit on a pickle bucket in the back, reading The Death of Ivan Ilyich and thinking about grad school.
将大卫那个时候的生活——我本可以拥有的生活——与我在帕萨迪纳和父亲一起拥有的生活相比，真是惊人。应该说，那里也不完美。青少年时期，我开始跟爸爸大吵大闹，16岁就搬出去了。我花了一个夏天在加州安大略的必胜客打工，跟吸毒者合住一间屋子。但区别在于我爸爸给了我视角。我知道什么是正常。我们有规律的睡觉时间，做模型火箭，周六早上上艺术课。我一直以为我会上大学。即使在那家肮脏的必胜客，我也会坐在后面的腌菜桶上读《伊凡·伊里奇之死》，思考研究生院。
In other words, when I strayed, I knew it. David's problem is that he doesn't know normal. That's how he could live in squalor with my mother, drunk on the couch for a month, and not call the paramedics. It's not his fault he doesn't know that people require medical attention when their skin turns yellow. He'd seen things like that many times before.
换句话说，当我偏离轨道时，我知道。大卫的问题是他不知道什么是正常。这就是他怎么能在那种肮脏的环境中跟我母亲住在一起，她醉在沙发上一个月，而他竟然不叫救护车。他不知道当皮肤变黄时人需要医疗关注，这不是他的错。他以前见过很多次那种事。
I can't even begin to describe how it feels to have to pick your mom up off the floor or have to wipe up her blood. I mean, Mom has hit her head on so many things at this point-- edge of a bad, a couch, the floor, the cement, those little cement rails that they put in front of a parking space that says your number on it. Yeah, all of those.
我甚至无法描述把你妈妈从地上扶起来，或者不得不擦去她的血是什么感觉。我的意思是，妈妈现在已经磕到这么多东西了——床边、沙发、地板、水泥，那些停车场号码牌前面的水泥小护栏。是的，所有这些。
Oh, man. That's rough.
噢，伙计。那真惨。
I mean, there's been plenty of times when she hit the back of her head and was bleeding profusely all over her pillows and everything else, and you have to be the one to stand there and keep the pressure on it, you know what I mean?
我的意思是，她后脑勺撞到地、血流如注弄脏枕头和所有东西的情况太多次了，你不得不站在那里按住伤口，你知道我意思吗？
You were telling me before about how, when you're in that home, when you're growing up with Mom and them, especially up in Minnesota with Mark, and you're just surrounded by alcoholics, and then probably even down here, where you just get to this point where you feel like that's normal.
你之前跟我说过，当你住在那个家里，当你和妈妈还有他们一起长大时，特别是在明尼苏达和马克在一起时，你只是被酒鬼包围，然后可能甚至到了这里，你只是到了那种地步，觉得那就是正常。
Yeah. It would seem like everything is just normal. Everything is cool. No big deal. You can come and look at the house and be like, what the [BLEEP] is going on here?
是啊。看起来一切都是正常的。一切都酷。没大不了。你可以过来看看房子，心想，这他妈是怎么回事？
Yeah. I mean, frankly, it's crazy.
是啊。我的意思是，坦白说，这很疯狂。
Right. Well, the only thing, actually, that I have to say has kept me grounded was you and Ethan and other people in the family who are living somewhat normal lives compared to what I saw every day in the house. And hearing about just the things that you talk about, things that Ethan talks about, the way that normal people integrate-- that has kept me grounded to where I knew that what was going on with me wasn't normal.
对。好吧，其实，唯一能让我保持清醒的就是你和伊森，以及家里其他过着相对正常生活的人，相比于我每天在家见到的。听听你们谈论的事情，听听伊森谈论的事情，普通人融合的方式——这让我保持清醒，让我知道发生在我身上的事情是不正常的。
So part of me has always wanted to become just like a normal member of society and do what everybody else does, but I know that's never possible for me. I mean, it's possible for me to come close to that, but I know I'll never be, you know, fully there because I started the race like 10 seconds after the gun went off. That's when I started to run.
所以我的一部分一直想成为一个正常的社会成员，做每个人都在做的事，但我知道那对我来说永远不可能。我的意思是，我可以接近那个，但我知道我永远不会完全做到，因为我在枪响后10秒才起跑。我是在那个时候开始跑的。
Well, you're starting right now.
好吧，你现在就在起跑。
Yeah.
是啊。
At 25.
在25岁。
Exactly.
正是。
It's four months after I first arrived in Florida. My mom is still in the nursing home. We're still waiting to hear from Medicaid. And I'm still trying to convince her to go into a substance abuse program. Then I get a call from the nursing home. My mother had been caught smoking in her room. It's a small infraction in the scheme of things, but it's against the rules, I guess. I fight with the administration, but they still give her 30 days to move out.
这是我第一次到达佛罗里达四个月后。我妈还在疗养院。我们还在等医疗补助的消息。我还在试图说服她去参加一个药物滥用项目。然后我接到疗养院的电话。我母亲被发现由于在房间里吸烟。这在整个计划中是个小违规，但我想那是违反规定的。我和管理部门吵了一架，但他们还是给了她30天的时间搬走。
David and I take her to the only place she can go, the condo at Century Village, which has been empty since David started staying at his girlfriend's, and has slid back into disorder.
大卫和我把她带到了她唯一能去的地方，世纪村那套公寓，自从大卫开始住在他女朋友家后，那里一直空着，又滑向了混乱。
I'm thirsty.
我渴了。
You're not going to go drink that soda in there, are you?
你不会去喝里面那瓶汽水吧？
Yes, I am.
是的，我要喝。
No, that soda-- no.
不，那瓶汽水——不。
What do you know?
你知道什么？
The soda is ancient. And the fridge is filled with roaches.
那瓶汽水太老了。而且冰箱里全是蟑螂。
That fridge is not filled with roaches.
那冰箱里可没全是蟑螂。
Why don't you take a look and see what's in here? Dead roaches everywhere. Little baby roaches.
你为什么不看看里面有什么？到处都是死蟑螂。小小的幼虫蟑螂。
Well, they're dead.
嗯，它们死了。
That's my mother. Adaptable, as usual, but oblivious to the big picture. Luckily, David is a little more stable now, with a job over at Marshall's. When he and I go out to the car to get Mom's stuff, we try to figure out what to do.
那就是我母亲。一如既往地适应环境，但对大局毫无察觉。幸运的是，大卫现在稳定了一些，在Marshall's找了份工作。当他和我去车里拿妈妈的东西时，我们试图想办法。
Right now, we're back to square one, right where she was right before this all got completely [BLEEP] out of control. And all it takes--
现在，我们回到了原点，就在她在那一切完全他妈失控之前的位置。而这一切只需要——
She's sitting in the exact spot.
她坐的位置一模一样。
Yeah, I know. I thought the same thing to myself, too. And the funny thing is that right now, all it takes is the wind to blow the wrong way and everything is right back to that same [BLEEP] because, obviously, she's going to be tempted to drink.
是啊，我知道。我自己也想到了同样的事。搞笑的是，现在，只要风往错的方向吹，一切就又回到了同样的鬼地方，因为很明显，她会受到诱惑去喝酒。
It's hard to feel like all these months have accomplished anything, even when, the next day, a spot miraculously opens at a subsidized sober living place not that far away. Of course, my mother doesn't want to go. We spend hours arguing about it. Her excuses are very frustrating. The pace will be too fast. She doesn't have the right clothes. She works better on her own. In other words, just another version of the same argument I've been having with her for the past four months.
感觉这几个月一事无成很难受，即使第二天，附近一个政府资助的清醒生活机构奇迹般地出了一个名额。当然，我母亲不想去。我们花了几小时争论这件事。她的借口非常令人沮丧。节奏太快。她没有合适的衣服。她自己工作效率更高。换句话说，这只是我过去四个月里一直跟她进行的同一个争论的另一个版本。
Josh, you don't seem to understand that I have physical, concrete, physical limitations, which I think are going to make it very difficult for me to run the pace of a residential program, where you have to go from this appointment to this appointment to this appointment, back for a meeting, da, da, da, da, da.
乔什，你似乎不明白我有物理、具体、生理上的局限性，我认为这会让我很难跟上居住项目的节奏，在那里你必须从这个预约跑到那个预约，又要赶回来开会，哒哒哒，哒哒哒。
Well, I don't-- I don't know why-- hold on a second. You decided you're ready for change, but then you're angry and fighting at every step of the way when we're trying to figure out the plan for yourself. You said you had a plan for yourself. What's the plan?
嗯，我——我不知道为什么——等一下。你决定准备改变了，但在我们试图为你制定计划时，你却在每一步都生气和抗拒。你说你为自己制定了计划。计划是什么？
The plan is to take care of my body, my mind, and my spirit.
计划是照顾我的身体、我的思想和我的精神。
But that is not an actual-- that doesn't specify what you're going to do. How are you going to do that? You're going to come back here?
但那不是一个具体的——那并没有说明你要做什么。你怎么做？你要回这里来？
Well, I own this place. I think I ought to come.
嗯，这地方是我的。我想我应该回来。
Well, how are you going to get your stuff? This is-- right now, if you don't go into the sober living place tomorrow, we're at square one. We're back in January. You're going to be here--
好吧，你怎么拿你的东西？这——现在，如果你明天不去那个清醒生活中心，我们就回到了原点。我们回到了二月。你会呆在这里——
Oh, I don't think that.
噢，我不这么认为。
You are sitting in the place where you almost died right now.
你现在正坐在你差点死掉的地方。
Josh, I'm barely able to get from point A to point B, and it takes me forever to do everything.
乔什，我几乎没法从A点走到B点，做任何事都要花掉我好长时间。
I understand. So why would you want to do that at home, alone, by yourself, with no resources, no transportation, no way to do anything for yourself? Why is that better?
我明白。所以为什么你想在家里，独自一人，没有资源，没有交通工具，没有办法为自己做任何事？为什么那样会更好？
I don't know. I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
我不知道。我不确定。我不确定。
That last recording is from a year ago. My mother ended up going to the facility, but she only lasted a few weeks. She's back at the condo now, where neither of our predictions have come true. She's drinking again, sporadically, but the house hasn't descended into chaos, either. David's back there, too. After a few more brushes with the law, David managed to complete all the requirements of his probation. He's now looking for another job to save up some money to get back in the studio for a demo. He's even talking seriously about going back to school.
最后那段录音是一年前的。我母亲最后去了那个机构，但只呆了几周。她现在又回到了公寓，我们的预测都没实现。她又开始喝酒了，偶尔喝，但房子也没陷入混乱。大卫也回那儿了。在几次与法律的冲突后，大卫成功完成了缓刑的所有要求。他现在在找另一份工作攒钱去录音棚做小样。他甚至在认真考虑回学校。
Together, they're maintaining. My mother is more broke than ever, but she's not homeless or dead. Still, it's hard to let go of the notion that I could save my mother or convince her to change, to realize that this might be what salvation looks like for her. At least for now. Nothing is getting better. But if it gets worse, I'm sure they'll call me.
他们在一起维持着。我母亲比以往任何时候都穷，但她没无家可归也没死。尽管如此，很难放下这种想法：我可以拯救我的母亲或说服她改变，意识到这可能就是她的救赎。至少现在是这样。没什么好转。但如果变得更糟，我相信他们会打电话给我。
Josh Bearman. He lives in Los Angeles. His mom passed away in 2012. He did a story about that for our show, which you can find at our website.
乔什·贝尔曼。他住在洛杉矶。他母亲在2012年去世了。他为此在我们的节目中做了一个故事，你可以在我们的网站上找到。
That's Josh's brother, AKA DJ Scraps. Today's program was produced by Alex Blumberg and myself, with  Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help for today's show by Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Our staff includes  Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
那是乔什的弟弟，即DJ Scraps。今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，参与者有简·玛丽、莎拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。埃曼纽尔·佐齐为今天的节目提供了制作帮助。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。我们的员工包括伊莉斯·伯格森、艾米莉·康登、金伯利·亨德森和塞斯·林德。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
As I said before in today's show, this show was originally broadcast in 2007. Vince Homenick and Norman Goodman, who you heard at the beginning of the show, they're still around, but they have retired from their job getting jurors into New York juries. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
正如我在今天的节目中之前所说，本节目最初于2007年播出。你在节目开头听到的文斯·霍梅尼克和诺曼·古德曼，他们依然健在，但已经从为纽约陪审团征召人员的工作中退休了。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心(PRX)传递给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-found, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's giving tours now of the This American Life offices.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他现在在为《美国生活》办公室提供参观服务。
Judy's the one that has the cute little shoes. And here's the lady who takes her clothes off all the time.
朱迪就是那个穿着可爱小鞋子的人。那个是老喜欢脱衣服的女士。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。